MANU BATRA: Welcome, folks.
Thanks for joining the session,
Protect Your Enterprise
Applications with Backup
for GKE and Anthos.
We'll start with
looking at History
of Storage Evolution
in Kubernetes,
get a deep dive
into new Kubernetes
Backup Service
for GKE workloads.
We also have with us
the Broadcom team,
who will share their
experience using
the Backup for GKE service.
Before we get into
details, let's
start with a quick
round of introductions.
My name is Manu Batra.
I am a Product Manager
with Google Cloud,
and I own container native
storage and data management
services.
Apparao, do you want to go
ahead and introduce yourself?
APPARAO CHITIKELA: Hi, folks.
My name is Apparao Chitikela.
Currently, I am working as
a Saas Platform & Delivery
Engineer at Broadcom.
MANU BATRA: Thanks, Apparao,
for the introduction.
Now, let's look at the evolution
of storage in Kubernetes.
We have seen terrific
customer adoption of GKE
for all types of workloads.
This includes
stateful workloads,
like databases, that were
uncommon in the earlier
waves of Kubernetes adoption.
With enhancements in
Kubernetes storage support,
customers are more
comfortable deploying
data-intensive workloads, like
databases inside containers.
The net result is
that GKE customers
are managing far more critical
data inside containers
than ever before.
But many Cloud
customers are still
held back from
greater adoption by
their service-level objectives
and backup requirements.
Additionally, we have
heard from customers
in more regulated verticals,
like finance, payments,
manufacturing, and
aerospace, that
have strict data backup
and lifecycle management
requirements.
These customers
are often blocked
from expanding their
use of GKE to include
production-critical
straightforward workflows.
Our goal is to unblock
traditional enterprise
customers from running more
stateful workloads with more
regulated data
inside GKE customers
and meet their backup
and BR service levels.
With that objective
in mind, we're
introducing a new Google
service, called Backup for GKE.
Backup for GKE is an
easy Cloud-native way
for customers running workloads
on GKE to protect, manage,
and restore their containerized
applications and data.
Now, let's get
into more details,
into what really
is Backup for GKE
and a bit more of
the architecture.
The service operates at
three different layers.
The bottom-most layer
is the data layer where
we take a copy of the data.
Today, we do support
Persistent Disk,
which is Google
Cloud's block storage.
In future, we will
also be supporting
additional types of
storage, including
file and other elements.
So the first part is we
take a copy of the data
and store it as a
part of the backup.
Second is, as a
part of the backup,
we also take Kubernetes objects.
And this is where a user can
define the scope of a backup.
A user can define a backup
to be an entire cluster,
a specific namespace
within a cluster,
or a set of namespaces.
Or a user can define a lot
more granular control and scope
of backup call applications.
And I'll talk more
about applications
in the following slides.
But once the user defines
the scope of backup,
we pick up all the Kubernetes
configurations and objects,
depending on the
scope of the backup.
We also orchestrate backups
within an application.
And this is to support
app-consistent backups.
A lot of applications
are crash-consistent,
but some applications like
to flush their memory,
or do QS-ing and un-QS-ing
pre- and post-backup.
To be able to accommodate
such applications,
there is a flexibility to create
application profiles, which
enables users to inject
scripts at par level for QS-ing
or other application-level
orchestration.
So as I've touched,
backup essentially
includes two different elements.
One is Kubernetes objects, and
second is the volume backup,
which is the Persistent
Disk data that we backup
as a part of the backup itself.
Now, as a part of backup,
there are multiple options.
As a user, you can choose
where the backup is stored.
So if there are data
residency requirements,
you can specify which region you
want the backups to be stored.
You also have ability to select
and skip certain resources.
If you're managing
secrets outside,
you can tell the backup service
to skip and not backup secrets
as a part of the backup package.
Same thing, you can also
decide not to backup volumes,
if there are other ways
you are backing up data,
or it's more for transient data
that you don't want to backup.
Another feature,
which is very critical
to protect against ransomware
and malicious deletions,
is time lock.
The service allows you
to time lock backups,
which will disable any
automated or manual deletion
of the backup, unless
the time lock expires.
This is a really
critical feature,
in case a ransomware
attack, or somebody
tries to delete those backups
with a malicious intent.
And of course, all data
is encrypted, by default.
Getting more into details
about protected applications.
So I touched upon a user can
define the scope of backup.
A user can define a
cluster as a scope
of backup, a set of namespaces.
Or, depending on
the scope of backup,
a user can define a
specific application.
And an application
can correspond
to something like a
MySQL, or a Redis Data,
or a Postgres database itself.
And this allows users to execute
QS-ing and un-QS-ing commands
pre- and post-backup.
We also support more complex
definitions of applications,
like an HR data
processing application,
which could be a combination
of a messaging bus, a database,
and a web services agent.
The system allows you to
group all those applications
into protected
application groups.
And the backup
orchestrates, knowing
that a particular application
is part of a larger component,
and orchestrates the backup
with that knowledge in mind.
So essentially, as a
part of the backup,
you can define a cluster, a
namespace, or an application
or application group as
a scope of the backup.
Backups are fine,
recoveries are better.
This is where the tool
provides multiple use
cases to restore the data.
You can backup a cluster,
restore the cluster
into a new cluster,
or into a new region.
The system also allows
you to backup a cluster
and restore a specific
namespace or an application.
This can be done in case there
was an accidental deletion
of a specific data set,
or an upgrade failed
and you want to restore the data
in its previous healthy state.
The system also allows
you to clone and scale
workloads in different regions.
So all these are
multiple use cases
that can be supported via
the backup and the recovery
workflows.
Getting into a bit more
details of restore options.
As a part of the
restore, the system
also allows users to
change certain parameters
before the backup is restored.
This may include changing
storage classes or replica
accounts.
An example could be, you backup
production environment, which
was running PDS SDs.
But for test and dev, you
are using PD Standard.
So this is where,
before you restore,
you can change storage classes
to map to the new environment
that you are restoring.
Another use case is sub-scope
restores where you can always
backup an entire cluster.
But at the time of
restore, you can decide
what is the scope of restore.
You may restore
only one namespace,
or a set of namespaces,
or one application out
of the entire backup.
Another feature that
was added to the service
is for delegated admin.
And this use case is
more around when--
let's say a cluster backup
executes at midnight.
But as an app
admin, you may want
to take an ad hoc
backup at 4:00 PM,
just before a critical
upgrade is kicking in.
So this allows cluster admins
to delegate certain authority
to application admins to
execute an ad hoc backup just
before critical upgrades
or critical changes that
are about to make an
application, namespace,
or a cluster.
Backup for GKE experience is
completely integrated into GKE.
So as you log into
your GKE framework,
you'll be able to see Backup and
Restore in the left navigation.
Once you get in there,
you'll be able to see
all the backup policies, all
the clusters that are protected
with the backup policies, when
was the last backup executed,
and what was the
duration of the backup.
The whole interface also allows
you to create new backup plans,
restore plans, the
intent being it's
a completely seamless
workflow as you
operate your workloads in GKE.
Now, I'll pass to
Apparao to talk more
about Broadcom's experience
using Backup for GKE service.
Apparao?
APPARAO CHITIKELA: Thanks, Manu.
So I'm part of Broadcom team.
So my team is Saas Platform.
So this thing, this Cloud,
it shows as the platform.
So in the platform, we
have different components.
Those are infrastructure,
monitoring, Kubernetes,
networking, identity,
and access management.
While using this platform,
different products teams
will deploy their applications.
So Broadcom software uses a
foundational Saas Platform
architecture to manage multiple
elements across regions
and lifecycle stages.
The core functional
uses Terraform modules
to describe the infrastructure,
node, networking,
and Kubernetes cluster used
to support Saas products being
delivered to the customers.
The environment spans
across development, verify,
and production, and spread
across multiple regions.
By using flexible modules,
we can create clusters
to various sizes, while
maintaining consistency
across environments.
Yeah.
This is-- it will give you
more details about the host
projects and shared VPC.
All service projects are
connected with the Shared VPC
project and will communicate
each of the applications.
So the Saas Platform
Foundation takes
advantage of a
cross-project communication,
using Google's Shared VPC.
This enables separation
between the GKE projects.
And product-specific projects
are projects for dB servers
that have not yet
been migrated to GKE.
Yeah, this slide talks about the
state of stateful applications.
So as with most of
enterprise companies,
we started our
Kubernetes journey
with deploying
stateless applications.
This helped us take advantage
of the GKE scale and cost
optimization.
Moving to GKE improved
our development velocity,
besides helping with
optimizing cost.
But the split
architecture created
some additional challenges,
as our application components
were split between
VMs and containers.
Because they are
stateful applications,
it takes a lot of additional
data management services
in the platform to trust it
with data, especially databases.
Modernizing applications
during the migration
by moving the
operators-based versions
allows us to add
operational flexibility.
We had stateful
applications on VMs
and stateless
applications on GKE,
creating application complexity.
In order to simplify the
operational environment,
we started exploring moving
stateful applications to GKE
as well.
So we'll continue.
So these stateful
applications, today, we
have about 150 stateful
workloads deployed in GKE.
This helps us
streamline operations
and remove a lot of
functional causes
by non-uniform involvement.
But a few challenges
remain, likely ability
to issue backup and disaster
recovery service level.
Remote some workloads to GKE,
but with very fragmented backup
solutions.
The fragment backup
solutions made
it difficult to
maintain consistency
and created
operational challenges.
Key requirements for critical
stateful applications.
Some of the use cases that will
help for key stateful workloads
are ability to achieve critical
backup and disaster recovery
service levels, ability
to recover an application
to non-healthy state in the
event of fault or corruption.
Other use cases include ability
to quickly scale and migrate
applications.
Backup for GKE provides us
with an integrated backup
and recovery platform to
achieve these critical use
cases, enabling us to migrate
additional workloads to GKE.
Key highlights from GKE backup.
We were particularly
impressed with the simplicity
of taking cluster backups
and ability to implement
standard backup policies across
our enterprise workloads.
Backup for GKE also supports
application-consistent backups,
besides crash-consistent backup.
This enables us to break
any soils of backups
across our organization.
Ability to take
incremental backup
helps us optimize cost without
compromising critical service
levels.
So our experience on
Backup for GKE service.
After [INAUDIBLE] introduced
us to the new offering Backup
for GKE, it unblocked a lot
of critical stateful workloads
to move GKE.
Before backup, we are using
storage backup directly.
It made it very
difficult to adhere
to service-level projects.
We are using Backup
for GKE service,
and we'll integrate it part
of our core platform services.
This will enable us to
standardize our backup
and disaster recovery policies
for the entire Kubernetes
application fleet.
Thanks.
So I'll hand it back to Manu
to continue the session.
MANU BATRA: Apparao,
thank you so
much for walking
through the use case
and how Broadcom is
leveraging Backup for GKE
to unlock additional
SQL workloads
and deploy them on GKE.
To recap, folks, Backup for
GKE is an easy Cloud-native way
for customers running workloads
on GKE to protect, manage,
and restore their containerized
applications and data.
Please reach out to your
Google Cloud contact
to get more information
on Backup for GKE,
and please let us know if
there are any other details we
can provide.
Thank you again so
much for taking time
to look at our session today.
And we'd love to
get your feedback.
Thank you all.